[Music]
Leslie Murphy was last on The Bachelor
in 2013 for Sean Lowe's season now she's
back for Bachelor winter games but her
comeback comes just months after major
surgery the travel bloggers found out
she had the bracha to breast cancer gene
and chose to undergo a double mastectomy
and get implants threw caution to the
wind when I went on The Bachelor the
first time threw caution to the wind
when I quit my job and started a travel
blog the caution of the wind when I did
the surgery staying with Bachelor Winter
Games it's like yeah I haven't been on
TV in five years but why not I've done
this before I can do this again and yeah
new year new me why not did you have any
concerns or any difficult moments just
in terms of doing a lot of these
athletic things that you guys did having
gone through surgery pretty recently it
has taken a while to get back to where I
was before surgery I I kept trying to
push it and trying to do these same
exercises that I was probably entirely
too soon but the human body is really an
amazing thing it it healed each and
every day and so when the producers
asked me about coming on with our games
they're like can you even do that can
you even participate in these things and
and by that point my doctor's had signed
off on everything they're like yeah do
whatever you want your implants are
gonna be just fine
what about it being dating after this
surgery was that the first time you'd
have gotten romantic and dated since at
all
it was an interesting thing just because
I could tell this story all day and I
can be all for early detection and early
screening and this is what I went
through but to actually tell this to
somebody or romantically involved with
and and telling them what to possibly
expect I've never done that before so
that in and of itself was a little
frightening yeah
and now you'll see that play out and
bachelor Winter Games for sure
you